[Music]
there's a company out there that offers
employees masturbation breaks with uh
what they call wink pods and vr
sounds like a british company what the
[ __ ] is this japanese japanese
pods they did say wank pods
whoa that's pretty great wow
how much money are they investing in
this and let's put a black light in
there and see
if it's glazed damn a black that's right
that's a good point like do you want to
get in there like after your homie just
did yeah you want communal masturbation
random stranger i don't know nah but you
gotta air that [ __ ] out because you know
like when you're jacking off there's
jack off steam what does what does a
jackpot go on like a thousand miles an
hour
what does a jackpot offer that a regular
pod does doctor right now i'm gonna say
cut cameras you need to go to a [ __ ]
doctor right now what does jack off
scene smell like
no i mean like
right
it's muscle burnt rubber i mean like if
a dude just jacked it in the room yeah
and you come in you're gonna smell the
essence of jacking off and like what
would you how would you describe it just
like like a guy [ __ ] having a cardio
exercise he's gonna sweat breathe he's
like axe do you guys sweat when you
masturbate
depends if joe jerks two dicks off when
he masturbates
i'm [ __ ] skiing come on guys
but also yeah what if it's like the 300
pound
uh jerry from accounting that just got
out like it's it's sweaty it's musky oh
dude in that little ball a little ball
is having a tough time it's like when
you sit on a toilet seat after somebody
it's still warm it is it is and what's
the interior feel like i'm not allowed
to act like a naive and i'm trying not
to be offensive with this at all you
hold your dick and you just do this
as much as you can i'm just trying to
ask a serious question like really um
really because somebody mentioned like
300 pounds like really big dudes you
don't sound like physically like oh yeah
you gotta like and then you gotta that's
what i'm what can you even get there
though like you know what i'm saying is
i bet they have a system that we don't
know about they definitely haven't you
right you know what i mean you know what
they probably do put the gun on the
table reach under the table oh that's
genius that's kind of smart
just kind of also assuming that the once
you put on the table and it flattens out
this way that the arm has the ability to
come around circumference no go down you
go down straight down
i'm not trying to be offensive here dude
they have arms bro you're bringing fat
in all right i just said large all right
picture of penguin trying to jack off
where's the opposable thumb yeah there's
no opposable thumb just saying like
they're portions everybody knows fat
dudes jerk off like this
dude that's pretty crazy that's a joke i
could never do
way to be limber they just take a
fleshlight everywhere they go
oh yeah you know what the dark knight is
you gotta put them on game it is a trick
question yeah yeah
it's a movie and seeing those suck
machines on instagram
there's girls that are oh no
you talk about girls
and guys hey you're talking about a wife
aren't you can you imagine saying that
look at that suck machine right there
you guys want to meet my suck machine
did you get any more dragon that's like
something that that the guy would say
i'm married with children
he's not the only guy who can get away
with it and still go get an emmy
and like say hey everybody we should
pray for africa thank you
i pray for him he's the only guy that's
a dark knight yeah this is about the
eighth time we've promoted the dark
knight are you guys getting paid for
this not yet not yet
we're hoping to get sponsored so there's
a suction cup feature at the bottom so
you can stick it into different places
and then this rotates on like three
different speed settings what and it
also goes up and down so imagine
rotation and up and down at the same
time in different speeds someone could
never do it
no such members
no suck machine
no suck machine holds a candle that
sucks machine okay real talk who here
has used the dark knight
we don't have the guts man can someone
send us one
i'd [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of it
it would [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you oh
yeah that's right so like i follow these
meme pages right and sometimes meme
pages need to make money and i think
they get sponsored by a lot of these
like vibrator companies and so it's
always like some kind of amazon review
where it's like it's like you wouldn't
believe this i came so many times i went
straight to sleep or whatever right yeah
and then the girl version is like
something like i was so wet i didn't
know how to [ __ ] i don't know there's
there's always something never say that
go ahead you said this on instagram
[Laughter]
brother
brother i snapped into a slim jump and i
stuck it up my [ __ ]
brother brother let me take something
brother i got so turned on i lifted my
own kitty started licking on my own
titty
that's a [ __ ] woman repeating a
sex toy that's what you're doing that's
how they talk
that's how they talk like wait it's on
instagram you said yeah so so me so me
and pages they'll get a brand name oh
yeah instagram.com don't get a brand new
for vibrators or suck machines or
[ __ ] pockets or whatever [ __ ] there's
always like there's always like a review
yeah like that is it crazy [ __ ] probs
or something yes yes like [ __ ] yeah
great mechanic
i don't know why i'm promoting them but
crazy [ __ ] prob or nugget or like
whatever like and then they have these
things like that
yeah young republicans does that too
[Laughter]
open-minded company is offering its
employees the opportunity to masturbate
during work hours company dude you can't
even order custom-built quote-unquote
wink pods help them out the unusual work
perk has been introduced by strip chat
an adult website oh
okay 200 employees
yeah so located within the brand cypress
office the four
high-tech pods will be kitted out with
masturbatory accessories
for the ultimate vr experience complete
with an oculus quest vr headset and 4k
led screen to watch the x-ray you can't
do this at home i'm not going to work
and do this but if you're if your work
is that like porn yeah why would you
want to how are you not desensitized to
your work or what if your home life is
an anti-masturbatory environment we all
know what i'm talking about yeah i've
heard that that's [ __ ] up
for that
environment i don't know that's [ __ ]
up talk about you got a bitch-ass wife
who won't let you jerk it yapping at you
all day she's not a segment stop going
like that about it
she won't let you alone like she won't
let you not be alone either she thinks
you're jacking off she'll give you any
privacy so you can get pops
now that i know it's strip chat that
makes sense
but then wait what's strip chest so it's
one of those pop-ups you get when you're
trying to look at a different site okay
like you know live jasmine or [ __ ]
hey what are you doing jacking off all
alone it's like one of those things oh
i thought she said live jazz men
it's just duke ellington porn
it's just live music
music he's like oh we about to jack
what are you doing jacking off all by
yourself
[Laughter]
it's really good because you got to jack
up with some jazz
[Music]
the jazz heads are going crazy dude hey
that's a great diy video
it's jasmine this reminded me of a time
i was going to cypress college and i
took sex ed and then the teacher was
this she was kind of like this
kind of decent looking milf blonde lady
at the first day of school she goes you
know if you guys
want to jack off in the middle class i
highly support that no she did not she
[ __ ] said that the guys just started
beating her and everybody laughed and it
was a ha and she was like no really like
i'm that liberal about your feelings and
if you feel like you might it reminds me
of this like she was like encouraging us
to jack off in front of her did you say
she was hot as well yeah she was
actually like a good looking but then
that's a sting operation
steve should have been in the class and
she goes and she would always go don't
forget my office hours are this oh no no
dude i [ __ ] swear to god wait how old
how old are you
i was like
20 19. the swat team was waiting outside
the bomb squad's there the whole class
she was telling the whole class like
every every class time she'd go hey if
you guys want to just whip it out and
you know everyone just go ha ha but like
everyone secretly was like she's got
something bro if anybody wants to do a
little bump of cocaine you think i'm
gonna care i don't care yeah i don't
care i'm a cool teacher i'm really cool
it reminds me of that she probably
[ __ ] them she might [ __ ] a ton of
students
but then cypress college i'm with nick
the cops yeah the swat team there's no
rule at cyprus yeah no community rules
yeah there's no rules when they get
hired they're like what are your
credentials do you like to [ __ ] students
yes
we've got space for you
looks like you checked yes on that you
want to [ __ ] students that's okay
damn that sucks that's something i just
wanted to remind you if you're gonna
check yes on wanting to [ __ ] students
gotta fill in the whole bubble
number two pencils please don't use pen
when we put it through the machine it
was it wasn't sure stab the pencil
straight through the bottom whole bubble
please thank you
machines
for job applications
they're like we're not going to look
through it we're just going to put
through the machine let's go the machine
will tell us whether or not you're a sex
offender yeah it's a good score good
score
98.
did i mention that in addition these
pods will house lotion lube and of
course tissues
well they got to how do you even have a
jackoff pod you know what there's a
business out there that built a jackoff
pod
they're probably just repurposing things
like telephone booths you know what you
know would be really sad it looks high
tech though that looks like an old
jurassic park 2 game bro
what if the whole thing moved while you
jacked off like 4d right now
and then missile water and stuff on the
other side that would be that's what i
got smells
it smells like crabs
and then jeff goldblum's like life
finds a way and you're like oh what
happened
but they leave that
didn't that cost money
license
how he's still rich you know what you
know it's the sad reality which i really
hope this isn't the case but like if
having that was just a big old publicity
stunt for strip chat to get like
attention yeah and they really have it
but they're like okay guys no one's
supposed to actually use that thing
that's our that's our big publicity tool
i'm okay with it always people are
jacking off on it like come on employees
will get to enjoy a 30-minute break to
masturbate during work hours as the
company said it aims to provide current
and attract new employees with a safe
comfortable space to rub one out because
you want to attract those kinds of
employees
what is this well strip chat is also
offering other companies the opportunity
to lease out its pods for up to 50
thousand dollars for six months
including adding a vip subscription to
its platform oh google where are you at
so they're the ones that created this
business this is ridiculous nobody
should be jacking off at work is it vip
or are you really in the bottom of the
ladder
you know this reminds me of high school
toilets right where they're there but if
you use it people are going to make fun
of you yeah people are going to [ __ ]
with you like did you take a [ __ ] right
now well what about this like how often
do you think people just in a normal
like office job actually do just like go
to the stall and jerk one out i 100 did
it sylvan learning center
that's them
the sylvan learning center coming
together
we got them you just missed the jasmine
[Music]
told him to deal with
[Music]
[Music]